[Music]
hey you guys it's Friday and look we're
doing video for our movie reviews sooo
for their very first time yeah we're
gonna knock out a quick review of 2001 a
Space Odyssey yeah Stanley Kubrick yeah
we're actually probably gonna do another
Stanley Kubrick movie we're probably
gonna do a Clockwork Orange next time or
the time after because we were at Target
the other day yeah it's known as tarjay
yeah it's like the French Oh Walmart
yeah and we happen to come across a
special edition like three Kubrick movie
set yeah $15 yeah I'm blu-ray it had
2001 had the shining on it which I
didn't have that on blu-ray and then it
had a Clockwork Orange yeah and I was
like man it's $5 a movie I gotta get
that so I got it and we watched them all
and man that's a good DVD that's a good
blu-ray yeah yeah so that's one you
should add to your collection if you can
find it you can probably find it on eBay
yeah we thank you I didn't know we just
happened to see it we were at Target for
something else and we just did that come
across it we weren't like looking for it
or anything I was like whoa and it seems
like a good it was it's a good deal
because all three of these movies cuz I
love Stanley Kubrick and all of his
movies are super rewatchable it is for
me I mean I have seen a Clockwork Orange
probably a hundred times I've seen The
Shining probably a hundred and twenty
times and I never get to I could watch
it every day
yeah and I wouldn't get to go through
those movies you can yeah you can watch
every day they're very very watchable so
yeah it was totally totally worth it yes
this one's about 2001 and that 2001 is a
masterpiece it's as good as The Shining
I would say that it's it's The Shining
of sci-fi yeah yeah I would think so too
it was it's a pretty sophisticated movie
when it came out a lot of people didn't
get it it was way ahead of its time in
many ways it was a milestone flick I
mean the special effects are outstanding
the space shots just set the stand
and you can watch it today on blu-ray
and you're like man I have a hard time
you know believing that this is the
1960s it looks like real spaceships yeah
it's amazing to me that this came out in
1968 because I mean here's the thing
Stanley Kubrick he's always been he's
done movies and lots of different genres
but he's always like whatever story he
wants to tell and whatever John Ruiz
doing he wants to do like the very best
thing or he wants to do something that
had never been done before so at this
stage I mean this movie came out in
spring of 1968 and prior to this sci-fi
wasn't really something that was taken
all that seriously it was just kind of
like horror you know you just had kind
of your big bug 50s movies and that kind
of crap so this movie was really kind of
like a turning point yeah for sci-fi
cinema because this was actually a
serious philosophical beautifully filmed
movie that took itself very seriously
and I think it was really I mean later
on you can see and even on the blu-ray
there's a bunch of interviews with all
these directors and stuff that were
influenced by this you know George Lucas
and James Cameron and you know all these
other kind of sci-fi directors that did
all these big sci-fi movies later on I
don't think a lot of these movies would
have happened no without mm no this was
a game-changing movie oh definitely you
know this movie was taken so seriously
that guys from NASA were working on it
yeah like instead of someone I haven't
having some Hollywood hack you know I'll
make you a spaceship yeah yeah I'll make
you a spaceship put a sparkler in it
yeah yeah you had guys who really do
design spaceships going yeah the
discovery should look like this you know
and this would you know that the layout
of the ship was all planned and the
interiors were all planned this the the
spacesuits were made by guys who
actually knew what spacesuits should
we're supposed to look like and how it
would look in the future you know now
this is 2001 as you know as imagined by
the 1960s right they were looking at it
from the viewpoint of you know with the
rate of innovation they were having in
the 60s they thought that you know the
progression would lead them to Mars
colonies and man Jupiter
you know by by 2001 you know they didn't
really you know realize that space had
kind of go out of style in the 70s and
80s but you know with the rate of growth
that they knew about then yes a lot of
this would be pretty plausible yeah and
it's funny because they showed a lot of
props that they were you know
conceptualizing for the movie you know
in the extras they actually showed a
laptop and their version of a laptop in
the 60s was a briefcase that you opened
up they had a typewriter in the bottom
and think it had a telephone yeah and it
had a television screen in it yeah
that's a laptop yeah it was pretty close
yeah but the movies good it was kind of
known as a head flick in the days you
know people had a hard time
understanding it because the themes were
way of advance even really you know I
can remember in the 80s not really
understanding the movie that well I
liked it but I was like what are they
yeah I kind of feel like it's one of
those ones where people I mean here's
the thing when it came out it seemed
like it was really ahead of its time
sure um a lot of critics were kind of
like I don't get it or they thought it
was self-indulgent or boring or
something but then there was like a lot
of other probably half maybe a little
more than half the critics including
like Roger Ebert and stuff recognized it
right away
yeah as being a masterpiece and a
game-changing and they had a motion
picture and then it seems like after it
had been out for a little while they
noticed that people were coming in high
as balls yeah trying to figure out this
wheel trying to figure the movie out so
they started tailoring it more to that
audience and then it seems like it got
kind of a cult following later on now I
feel like this is not so much yes it is
a movie but I feel like it's more of a
symphony in three or four parts and I
almost kind of feel like it gives me the
same vibe as like Fantasia if that's not
too weird a comparison to make this
octave this obviously has an overarching
theme and things that connect its three
or four parts together which Fantasia
didn't really have but it's a similar
kind of thing where it's just kind of
like a visual feast and there's
like classical music and everything is
just a spectacle yeah then there's kind
of deeper philosophical issues yeah a
lot of people a lot of people thought
that the movie didn't make sense there
was something just made up that's when I
was a kid I asked my dad said dad what
is this movie back dads buddy's name
doesn't mean anything it does mean
something my dad just wasn't really
advanced enough to grasp it yeah it's
like for movies mashed together they're
all interrelated what happened with
Australopithecus like three and a half
million years ago that's one part of the
movie what happened to a guy named
Hayward on the moon and this secret
mission that's another part of the movie
the secret mission to Jupiter and then
Bowman being taken beyond the infinite
it's in this light for the movies mashed
together they do make sense everything
in the movie has an explanation it's
kind of in a way a lot like Prometheus
and but but I think you know higher brow
them then Prometheus and Prometheus is
run the mean theus is hard to understand
because there's a lot missing from it
and I think a lot of it was
intentionally missing to leave you'd
like in wonder I really think really
Scott was trying to do 2001 we have
Prometheus oh yeah - Kubrick does a more
effective job of telling you a story and
not giving you all the pieces there are
there the pieces are there but you
really have to pay attention especially
when how comes in the story
Hal is like one of the main characters
through one of the biggest parts of the
story he's an artificially intelligent
computer who's managing the ship he's
really kind of like the main character
him and Bowman Oh even though Bowman's
more robotic than how you just got to
see the movie to appreciate it
it does make sense Hal is not
malfunctioning really he's doing what
he's told to do he find out at the end
of that sequence what the deal was the
crew wasn't supposed to know a certain
thing and we're supposed to understand
what the Jupiter mission was about until
they got there
so how interpreted his orders in a
certain way which back in the day that
really can
used a lot of audiences you know like
why did the computer go crazy well
you're asking an artificially
intelligent being to lie that's the
problem yeah he was supposed to not make
errors and not give misinformation but
that was exactly what the humans asked
him to ask you to do it was almost like
developing neuroses yeah well his only
way out of this conundrum was to get rid
of the crew yeah all right because he
could because the mission had priority
the mission was more important than the
crew all the conflicts in his orders
about the crew said well the best thing
I can do is just get rid of the crew and
I'll continue the mission without him
yeah because we're going to unplug him
yeah because he was malfunctioning yeah
or they thought he was mouthwash right
and after they were afraid that he would
sabotage the mission and he was afraid
that they would sabotage the mission so
like I said the two things were at odds
with each other now like I said that
this whole thing about like I said this
isn't kind of four parts now the germ of
the idea with the the monolith on the
moon being from the aliens and like
helping people along their evolutionary
path or whatever that actually came from
the arthur c clarke short story the
sentinel and so that was where that idea
came from and then arthur c clarke and
stanley kubrick got together and
basically wrote this screenplay
and novel at the same time like while i
was going on I mean arthur c clarke was
working on the book while stanley
kubrick was working on the thing so they
were working on the screenplay at stuff
together
now if you read the arthur c clarke book
it's a lot you know it's a book it's not
a visual medium so obviously there's a
lot more lot more to it made clear yeah
in the book that's not made clear in the
movie but Kubrick said that he wanted to
leave the film ambiguous he wanted a
film that was more visual and not so
much based on words there's really not
much dialogue in it there's not a lot of
sound in it other than music but he did
want but like I said you you can kind of
get even with just a really rudimentary
viewing of it you can get that this
monolith
is an alien technology of some kinds of
manifestation of their that is at
different stages of human evolution is
coming along and like giving us a little
push or like helping us out you know 3 4
million years ago the monolith comes to
earth when we're author at
australopithecines and it shows humans
how to make tools which how to develop
forward weapon which they use to kind of
dominate their environment
which gives rise to artificial
intelligence right which can give rise
to beings and or things like the
monolith people yeah because it's
inferred that this is a kind of a
galactic level machine intelligence but
it's beyond that it's almost a godlike
spirit yeah like a pure energy type of
rock not even beings I wouldn't know I'm
just like a Galactus yeah it's far
beyond a human's ability to comprehend
and modern terminology it's probably
some kind of machine intelligence that
is evolved into something that's like
pure energy and it's probably not a
single individual it's probably some
kind of weird galactic collective and
it's now in the role of nursemaid it's
running a nursery its galaxy or group of
galaxies and making sure that life
progresses maybe to make more things
like it mankind is yeah humans and
mankind and animals or biology life or
biological life is not the end result
that's just one of the stages that's why
it does the things that it does biology
is a certain stage and then you become
kind of trans biological into living
machine and artificial intelligence and
then living machine the next stage is
the next rut just energy or work it
seems like they almost don't have bodies
I guess no saying I think it's also
extra dimensional because yeah when
Bowman's take and it seems like he's
shown huge galactic events that are
somehow important
different worlds and then different
states of being possibly other
dimensions and yeah and he's taken to a
place where they do to him exactly what
you see you won't understand it unless
you read the book and you it's explained
later in 2010 the sequel yeah that does
actually kind of explain a lot yeah it
explains a lot of what you see but back
in the sixties people were left hang in
there like what the what happened it's
like what the space guy yeah it's weird
room and it's like then he's older and
conscious and concepts like biology just
being one of the stepping stones in life
that what that eluded people of the
sixties yeah it just it just did like
and you know what my dad couldn't
understand it he loves science fiction
just he reads science you didn't read
science fiction made by scientists he
met he read you know he was into that 50
science fiction big monsters yeah big
animal right but this is it's almost
like less a science fiction movie is
almost kind of like it's using science
fiction is almost kind of like a
philosophical treatise or it's making
this kind of allegorical statement about
you know ancient alien I guess you can
say it was ancient alien so this is an
ancient alien this actually should have
been one of the one of the one of them
you know about we're doing it now so we
wine his dog is interrupting it but this
should have been right there this is
where that came from it and this this
movie was a step was a milestone without
this movie a lot of science fiction as
you know it would have never happened
because the standards were raised up so
high with these shots you know this
movie actually had corporations and
governments and NASA was involved in
this in this making of this movie on the
blu-ray there's a in one of the
additional bonus features they actually
have a guy a corporate guy who's
involved in aerospace saying that this
movie is gonna increase and improve the
awareness of civilians mission as he
puts it the public and and make them
confront the the likelihood that
we will eventually meet
extraterrestrials and they will be
millions of a years advanced and that we
won't be able to grasp with what they
are that you know you have to look at it
in this point of view imagine you were a
frog that jumped on the side of a car
and then the car started driving and it
started driving down the freeway and the
driver reached out and grabbed you and
put you on the dashboard that frog Kant
doesn't know what a car is doesn't know
what a human is doesn't know what a
freeway is can see out the the data see
out the front of the windshield and not
understand the world is being presented
to him in a car going 80 miles an hour
Bowman goes through that when he's taken
beyond the infinite all right and deals
with these extraterrestrials they're not
even physical all right time that stops
making sense you'll see when you get
there
yeah he's basically transformed by this
literally he's transformed by this event
yeah and like I said you know there are
so many interpretations this movie like
many of Kubrick's movies because he
always did kind of a mythical yeah the
subtext like things like ambiguous like
yeah you know I guess there's you can
you can read this movie as like a
Nietzschean ya you know thing between
the ape and the ubermensch like yes man
rising above is involvement dominated is
like the transitional phase between that
which which really does apply you can
also see this as almost kind of like a
retelling like a modern retelling of the
Odyssey you know with Bowman being kind
of the ulysses figure and with Hal 9000
being the Cyclops you can see things
that way because like I said Kubrick
liked to do
mythological stuff like he did in The
Shining with you know Theseus and the
Minotaur and the maze and all that kind
of stuff there was a lot of that [ __ ] in
there but like I said Kubrick like to
leave things ambiguous arthur c clarke
kind of clarified things a little bit
more particularly in the book yeah he
did later on but I think Kubrick was
more interested in leaving things open
to interpretation um you know but like I
said I feel like I feel like it's a
pretty straightforward maybe in 1960s I
could see how this could kind of blow
your mind yeah I feel like people
nowadays are more
to the idea of artificial intelligence
because we're so much closer to it are
more open to the idea of you know alien
intelligences and how that's not that
far-fetched so maybe this was just kind
of way ahead of its time I don't think
people would have as much trouble
nowadays maybe trying you know figuring
out what they're talking about even the
end part with bowmen and the in the room
and everything yeah I don't think it's
all I that is a super creepy saying I've
seen it's like one of the creepiest
things especially when they show him
standing in the room with the spacesuit
and he's like older like his face and
he's like a ghost freaky-looking
most limericks me mostly D in this movie
the way it's portrayed with the sound
effects and everything way everything's
shot dealing with the monolith is creepy
yeah because dealing with an unknown
godlike force would be creepy yeah
alright now I'll help you guys out those
of you seen the movie haven't seen the
movie yet
I'll read the book really everything to
understand the movie is there it's it's
in there alright you have to read into
certain things alright but I'll help you
along a little bit in the book the
little australopithecines characters
actually had names and they had roles
and they actually did certain things and
there's it's explained a little bit
better man early man is in the
australopithecines era was getting its
ass kicked by competition and predators
the monolith saw the Australopithecus
rule epiphysis as a group that was like
well man this is the future here you
know in on this planet so it had
selected Australopithecus and certain
Australopithecus individuals and
basically it showed him how to make
tools yes but it also gave them ambition
and it made them killers they killed
their competition and in the very and
from that they got stronger and they
were able to dominate their environment
and they could become the dominant
species on the planet
and this is illustrated in the movie by
the main Australopithecus with a bone
he'd been he killed his first enemy he'd
been smashing animals that they were
eating too he throws the bone into the
air and Kubrick so it shows it spinning
through the air and then it transforms
in
bomb spinning in through the air
transforms into a nuclear weapons
platform into earth orbit around the
earth which is the extreme manifestation
of Technology of weapons technology of
bone
the weapons technology is what made man
leave the planet become a spacefaring
race and also invent artificial techni
artificial intelligence which is how
yeah
without that step other things after man
could not app it could not arise and
it's and this all this high-tech stuff
arises from the animal kingdom and
natural selection basically survival of
the fittest so that's what the movie and
that's why they're playing like
Nietzsche and music you know yeah that's
what they're getting to man is not the
end result man is just one step along
along the way so we can't put modern
moral judgments on what's happening now
this is serving a greater good millions
of years from now yeah that's what
they're talking like I said I've always
seen this as a very optimistic movie you
know what I mean yeah maybe some it's
very creepy it's very unsettling um bad
[ __ ] happens in it but ultimately I feel
like it's it's almost kind of like
encouraging it's like humans we can
transcend our bodies yeah transcend our
environment right
and so I find that very optimistic maybe
other people don't but I fight I feel
like it's a very opportunist and that's
what's happening at the end of the movie
which mystified me for a long time when
Bowman is taken beyond the infinite the
aliens put him in a place and they
accelerate his biology yes so he can
transcend biology and become what is
shown to you as the audience a child
yeah a star child and the star child is
a is what the aliens turned Bowman into
so he could actually transcend biology
yeah and that comes into play in the
sequel 2010 which which will have
yeah dad movies way that movies written
is very easy to understand very
pedestrian and it kind of explains a lot
of stuff that happens in the first one
and the reveal is like when you have
your oh of course of course that's what
I was seeing yeah some of that I've
given to you right now but there's a lot
of deeper issues in this movie yeah I
mean like I said it's very this movie is
very Kubrick II and I can see how a lot
of people you know it's very long
there's not a lot of dialogue in it a
lot of the shots are very very they go
on for a very long time and so I can see
how maybe if you kind of have a TBH it
like you wouldn't be able to sit through
it but it's it's like a visual feast
like I said it's almost like a symphonic
like sitting through a symphonic kind of
you know for movements and stuff like
that so it's just something you kind of
have to let wash over you yeah I mean
there is a plot there is a theme yeah
and things don't appear out of nowhere
it's on purpose and that you can even
there's even dialogue to show you when
why and where the Hal 9000 computer
decided to take to take on the mission
on its own yeah it's there you just have
to like all of Kubrick's movies is you
know yes it's open to interpretation but
he kind of leaves a lot of clues there
for you to use and part of the Jupiter
mission almost becomes a horror movie
where it feels kind of like the Overlook
Hotel where Bowman by himself trying to
survive on that damn [ __ ] that is a
really really scary
yeah part of the movie and he basically
has to murder how because how is a
living conscious machine intelligence
yeah he has to kill it or you might as
well be I mean the aliens don't
differentiate differentiate you'll find
later yeah but then he finds a message
that was left behind that kind of told
him what the mission was about yeah and
that's why how decided to knock him off
anyway yeah you'll see when you get but
like I said the interesting thing about
the character of Hal even though he's
the monster of the movie he's also kind
of like the most human character yeah
he's also a hero too he's trying to do
what he was told to do yeah and he
doesn't really know like he doesn't
well I guess because of the programming
yeah they told him that the mission was
most emotion was the most important so
he and that the humans could not know
what the mission was until they got to
June and if they found out they found
out interpreting that is does I should
get rid of them and well especially when
they said well he's malfunction we got
to turn him off and he's like oh no no
no yeah I'm more capable than you are
when it comes to this mission right
because really if you go by the laws of
this movie the Hal 9000 computer was the
next step in human evolution yeah that
it was our replacement in the
evolutionary scheme of things so it was
a superior being we can't be human
centric yeah okay well that's you
because it seems to be that the purpose
of human beings was to make things like
the how and beyond right so that's
that's how I wound up like I said there
was a little bit of Frankenstein going
on there to where that's like you know
we made something and it kind of went a
bit awry but it was human error and his
programming so it was our mistake but
like I said so was it wasn't
Frankenstein - it was his mistake
thinking that he could usurp I can make
life which nobody else can do and you
know which is a similar thing we talked
about it a little bit on our Prometheus
review how the the whole thing of like
hubris and making in stuff but like I
said it seemed like even though bad
should happened and how you know killed
everybody it was almost kind of like
like you said it was a necessary step on
the path to some yeah better what way
I'm interpreting this movie is not a
movie of where the the universe is
seeing us as something that's good or
evil all right that's not the way the
universe the universe is indifferent
yeah and Caprica said exam yes the
universe is indifferent and the universe
is indifferent about humans humans are
just one of the phases in this path of
development that these extraterrestrials
put in motion yeah so in other words in
the way I'm looking at it it humans were
just one of the steps along artificial
intelligence which Ament eventually
leads towards real
which is this monolith Thanks this good
like these so you're kind of like it
that's almost like one of the steps you
have to do that right and then the next
step is you transcend your biology
altogether right become like a PA it's
about trance here energy so this whole
thing about whoa hey they made the
humans killers well yeah because without
that then this transhumanism and all
this other stuff later on higher up in
the scale of development because that
could have never happened because humans
are in the animal world you know I mean
they're confined to the animal world
right so that had to happen right for
sure that for their gold for their gold
for the bride it's a deep flick it's a
deep voice yeah and like I said it's you
know it does help I guess I can see why
a lot of stoners got into this movie
because it is it is kind of you know fun
to watch you get high as balls you're
watching the movie or you get drunk and
watch the movie it's kind of cool you
know and like I said it has scary
moments it has like beautiful it's it's
a really really overwhelming sensory
it's good it's good and you know like I
said we'll probably be doing another
Kubrick flick probably do 2010 - yeah I
should do that yeah but probably the
next one will do is a Clockwork Orange
cuz yeah and I've seen that movie a
zillion zillion times and I never ever
ever get tired if you can find that blue
ready to find that Kubrick blu-ray that
hey yeah that was an exclusive or we
weren't looking for it like I said we
just kind of happened to see it very
satisfied with that purchase yeah it was
a really good deal five dollars apiece
yeah The Shining they have tons of
extras on them and everything and The
Shining looks fantastic yeah well
awkwar-- corns looks really good yeah
it's good I can't wait to do Clockwork
Orange that's one of my favorite movies
of all time look there's Jenni's piston
shirt I'll plug the shirt you can change
it
all right so that'll wrap up our review
of 2001 a Space Odyssey from 1968
Stanley Kubrick look check it out if you
have not seen it it's actually lassic
you really have to see it and remember
if you like the show to like share
subscribe on all your social media share
with all your friends we're also on some
other formats and I'll put links down in
the description to all our different
channels and where they are instead
she's growing that she's gone
and also if you'd like to financially
support the show you can go to our
patreon page at patreon.com slash 13
o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com org I don't remember and
you'll find it and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account if you'd
like to give a one-time donation also
check out our
zazzle store at zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock you can get this shirt and a
bunch of other cool ones yeah a van
Ripper and a tote bag yeah the Atlanta
rip winston demon child man said you
could yeah yeah man said you can do it
yeah so you should get no sitamma shirt
yeah oh [ __ ] I gotta make that cheetah
shirt drinking keel out of a barrel
5-gallon gold Zara that was wonderful
what a wonderful visual image that was
and yeah so that will do it for this
particular installment remember our
regular shows regular episodes go up
every Tuesday and our movie music up
every Friday and we will see you next
time bye